alors cette info mais les helvètes la
manouane comme tout bio it when a man
show je trouverai une chaîne youtube en
anglais mois avec un peu de chance
j'aurai deux abonnés les amis ce jeu est
extrêmement glauque mais il a attiré mon
attention attention pas intention je
sais quoi je parle alors on va jouer un
médecin si vous voulez on a un corps
humain devant nous tu auras cette forme
là ok c'est à dire qu'on voit
l'intérieur du corps humain d'accord le
coeur les poumons les organes tout ça on
connaît bien donc en gros soit le corps
est malade et on choisit la vie c'est à
dire qu'on va devoir le soigner soit le
corps est en pleine santé ont choisi la
mort c'est à dire qu'on va devoir
l'empoisonner jusqu'à causer le décès du
mec c'est glauque on va faire les deux
on va commencer par la vie parce que moi
j'adore l'amour plus que la haine donc
ont choisi l'amour et l'attention des
élèves ok choix du service on peut aller
qu'en faculté de métier on n'a pas le
même pour aller aux cliniques ou en
hôpital c'est juste qu'ils arrivent on
est en interne à votre premier cas fait
bonne impression n'inquiète pas nommer
votre patient j'ai mal soient les
difficultés modérées modéré pas grave ou
mortel ça va être hyper duroueix demandé
répondait des médecins mais tronquée fc
bonsoir scutin prière les médecines que
tu peux croire au dessus au fait si tu
peux qui rôdent en gros ça ici le corps
de la personne ont peu de chic et son
système circulatoire et respiratoire
digestif osseux nerveux rénale
immunitaire musculaire et là la moitié
des gens déjà quitté la vidéo c'est
normal des fois des petits trucs comme
ça qu'ils apparaissent et en fait on
peut les récolter hockey et ça nous
donne des points bio voyez ici j'en ai
quatre on voit ici qu'il a un problème
au système nerveux et qui l'a problèmes
circulatoires avec alors carte bio on a
ici la liste de ces symptômes il a
paralysé il a des sautes d'humeur des
maux de tête de la fatigue des vertiges
des courbatures et des gonflements des
jambes il a clairement problème au
cerveau qu'on va tout de suite allé voir
son cerveau on va lui faire un examen
neurologique une irm il irait mais comme
ça c'est la totale merde j'ai pas
récolté assez de points bio [ __ ] ou
alors j'ai fait exprès pour illustrer à
quel point les points bio c'est
important là on va essayer de trouver ce
qu'il a pour moi c'est un truc au
cerveau c'est clair c'est clair et net
coûtait déjà une fois j'ai joué à
docteur maboul
à partir de là je peux dire je peux me
démerder mais pour moi clairement le mec
a des vertiges dessoude humeur et des
malades et mal de tête c'est forcément
un truc au cerveau ou alors je suis mère
d'un résultat du test positif positif
positif [ __ ] on a trouvé trois trucs
il a un accident vasculaire cérébral un
caillot sanguin et de l'hypertension ok
alors les traitements c'est un problème
au coeur c'est exactement ce que j'ai
dit flash back c'est forcément un truc
au cerveau ou alors je suis merde on est
d'accord
ici on a donc les traitements possibles
donc on va lui filer une thrombolyse ça
coûte très cher on oublie on va lui
filer des diurétiques donc comme pouvait
le voir les pilotes mon possible pour
chaque symptôme chaque symptôme
swann nouveau symptôme tremblements hop
tas de merde là je peux y souscrire la
thrombolyse c'est parti yes et
maintenant on va résoudre le problème
d'hypertension et on sera pas mal ça
coûte 6 allez donc là on voit que le
traitement est en cours et le but c'est
d'arriver à 100% de guérison n'est qu'à
7 % avec un temps on va lui fut les mecs
à nombre de médoc à bouffer ses
terribles nouveau symptôme pulsations
cardiaques irrégulière [ __ ] son
système circulatoire prend tellement
cher faut qu'on résolve le problème
on peut maintenant résoudre des
problèmes qui est l'hypertension lui
souscrivant bien sûr un abonnement et d
alpha bloquants ces partis prescrire cet
encours son état va bien évidemment
s'améliorer en test est excellent niv
ça peut être parkinson ah oui il a des
tremblements mec c'est peut-être
parkinson le mec il a tous les problèmes
du monde quoi c'est génial il cumule
tout ohlala on va lui faire une analyse
de sang mais que c'est un truc bateau ça
il faut le faire ça c'est horrible
regardez sa vie baisse quoi cette double
pas en vigueur le crous a trouvé un
nouveau symptôme anxiété non mais ouais
ok j'ai lancé une évaluation
psychologique c'est sûr c'est ça le
problème c'est sûr et ben voilà il a dû
stress chronique est une dépression
nerveuse et bars mais qu'on va te
traiter allègrement aux plats suivi
psychiatrique c'est parti et ensuite
antidépresseur au niveau aa chez pas
l'étude des palettes une fois que c'est
bon j'ai les sous son stress chronique
on lui paie des antidépresseurs on lui
prescrit par dont on paye pour lui
prescrire ce génial là normalement mais
ces traitements vous marchez et il va
vivre
on va quand même récolté d'études on
n'est jamais à l'abri d'un symptôme en
plus qui fait chier ça d'urgence j'ai
mal a été admis dans un état critique en
salle d'urgence les médecins
intensifient leurs efforts pour sauver
j'ai mal événements suivants les tests
réussis sur 25 % moins cher 25 % plus
rapides les traitements soit 520 me sens
plus rapide victoire
merde merde merde merde qu'est ce qui
peut avoir qu est ce qui peut avoir est
l'un des trois hommes le loup bleu mort
moi aussi apparemment on va analyser
parkinson il a des tremblements mes mecs
c'est sûr tu tellement qu'on allait
aller mon gars ça va aller ça va là les
tiens le coup tient le coup tient le
couteau par les crises d'épilepsie à
leon lance on lance on lance les l'autre
c'était pas falot graphie c'est parti
vite il nous faut des tuiles nous faut
des tulipes a crevé
tu en as et résultats parkinson c'est
bon le basket c'est bon il a parlé de ça
commence white parkinson c'est parti
allez vas-y gpal est une [ __ ] mais non
mais là c'est une blague c'est l'argent
qui dirigent le monde toujours l'argent
on y va il va crever et il a une démence
le mec devient fou il a parkinson il a
mal au cou il a tous les problèmes du
monde allez faut que ça aille vite
c'est superbe il va passer la nuit
malheureusement j'ai toujours aimé dire
cette phrase elle et sa famille et est à
son chevet pour le motiver
il a gardé vidéo de mac faye qualité en
même temps tout va bien parce qu'il a
souscrit un abonnement donc on en déduit
que du coup c'est mal fait car les taux
qui regardent les mecs il faut que ça
aille vite là
je vais du traité le truc contre la
démence je lui ai mis tous les
traitements en compte tous les symptômes
qui affecte le cerveau il va crever
nouveau symptôme père de mémoire
changement personnalité il est mort
tu meurs
mais qu'en fait on peut y arriver tiba
on fait tous les tests ont fait tous les
tests courage courage mon gars on va
sauver j'ai mal les années à l'est
[Musique]
ok maintenant c'est l'équipe red cherry
système immunitaire par an
vous avez perdu
j'aime aller morts en 2 188 jours
rapport d'autopsié le système nerveux
jemal s'est effondré en premier à cause
d'une maladie parkinson [ __ ] j'y étais
qu on n'a pas réussi à le sauver un
temps le mec s'appelle j'ai mal à partir
de là on bombarde mauvais pied quoi bon
allez on y retourne mec je m'en bats les
couilles je veux sauver une vie c'est
quoi tes symptômes maux de tête vertiges
sont d'humeur douleurs à l'estomac
douleurs aux jambes gonflement des
jambes ça c'est un problème de
circulation c'est sûr et certain positif
qui a un hangar d'accord il a un caillou
ou maltraitées tout de suite c'est parti
d'accord on n'a pas l'étude plus tard
voulait faire de grandes études j'allège
l'aptitude on m'a dit pour sa folle et
une cahute un gars est soigné ok ensuite
on va s'occuper un peu de son cerveau il
a des douleurs à l'estomac et d'autres
trucs ça doit être du stress chronique
hop on va faire une électro [ __ ] il
sera mort avant que j'ai réussi à
prononcer ce mot correctement nouveau
symptôme faiblesses musculaires perte de
reflex ou ça c'est le cerveau ça y est
un blâme au cerf-volant ok maintenant il
a un gros problème au niveau du coeur
qu'il faut absolument j'analyse sarr
soit il à une arythmie soit il un
cholestérol élevé je pense qu'il un col
et en relève et je les ai vus hier au
burger qui ne fait pas le mec tristan
l'élever je suis bien tombé on est bien
ok on paie le cholestérol
alors attention et si tu sais parkinson
le retour est ce que cette fois on va
vaincre parkinson cette [ __ ] de
maladie de merde y est allé par kingson
ça dégage de vos symptômes fatigue ça
c'est inquiète mais j'ai un rhume se
fatiguer inquiète ça c'est sûrement une
l'hypertension ça rentre dans madame est
juste le jeu j'y comprends mais vous
imaginez vraiment des études en médecine
mais tellement dur à l'élire aime à les
lire mrm [ __ ] tu positif enfin
j'aimerais pas mais je sais qu'il a un
truc aller à lait du mois ce qui l'
accident vasculaire on souhaite sa de
spin ok mais que j'ai tellement dessus
on n'a jamais été aussi riche
est ce que à la limite on regarde pas la
thune pour nous et on ne soigne pas non
plus qui remettent ça ce qui est relou
c'est des fois j'ai fait des tests mais
entre temps il a chopé la maladie donc
je dois refaire les tests tout est
négatif j'ai même un dépressif est moins
négatif que ça mais on a le bras cassé
un arrêt cardiaque ça fait juste de 194
jours tel hôpital pour une grippe [ __ ]
c'est pas la grippe
bon faut pas un truc là dans l'hôpital
où elle est cet homme mourir et on va
faire un bon pour le départ de thierry
et alors peut-être qu'en fait je suis
nature vilaine et je suis plus doués
pour tuer quelqu'un que pour le sauver
c'est ce qu'on va voir
objectif tuer john smith a il est déjà
parent de moneygall mais qu'il n' y
viennent de vie moyenne excellent
continue d'aller au fast food où les
jours mais que c'est parfait ce parti
alors hop grippe développer h1n1
développé
joe smith attraper une très grosse
grippe john smith été infectées par le
h1n1
et ce n'est que le début mon pote
le mot thorax mais qui va perdre sa
[ __ ] de zoom et du coup tout le reste
va décliner et j'aurai enfin gagné à ce
jeu vidéo devant mes abonnés c'est
l'heure du peuple peu de mots thorax et
serrée entre moins un ordinateur je suis
à 55 % de ville à 42% de guérison cancer
du côlon aux [ __ ] on peut attendre
des trucs horribles de la taxe sur tous
les fronts le digestif le musculaire les
militaires tout tout tout le mec il est
mal les amis c'est bientôt la fin de
john smith ci possède actuellement une
fibromyalgie la maladie de crohn une
salmonellose un caillot sanguin peu une
gastro entérite une embolie pulmonaire
dans la lah il en train de soigner de
ouf et avec ses shows à faux clash avec
le cancer du côlon aux places a drop of
play beat it gets parce que c'est non 4
6%
si je suis prêt smart inspiratoire tout
est fini
la miss l'air dans cette vidéo sur
boeing je sais plus trop quoi bon le
lien de cet os oui jouer au jeu
n'hésitez pas allez messieurs vous a plu
eh ben je suis très surpris je pense pas
que j'allais autant rentrer dans le des
liens en fait c'est très bien fait et
même t'apprends des noms de maladies et
les effets que ça étouffe ensuite ce
soir médecin pendant une minute puis
après tu comprends pourquoi t'as pas
fait médecine mais pourquoi tu es devenu
youtube je vous souhaite une santé de
fer et de bonnes maintenant je le répète
voilà c'est bien sa famille et a très
vite dans une prochaine vidéo où je ne
serai pas mettre sa surtout pas
[Musique]
oh